[Music]
and finally what royal Revelations
appeared in obit sco's endgame that led
to the book being quickly removed from
the shops on the day of its release
Alexander lman joins me now with the
story Alexander thanks for joining
spectator TV uh the Royal has been back
in the news this week with the release
of Royal correspondent omed sc's new
book uh it quickly had to be removed
from the bookshelves in the Netherlands
tell us what happened there well the
trouble is James is that as luck would
have it there is this translation of
omed scobby and I think calling him a
royal correspondence putting it a bit
strongly his new uh book end game came
out and what's very interesting is that
in the English version Omid as we must
call him reveals that there are two
members of the royal family who were the
racist Ro s who apparently when the when
megon was pregnant with her first child
by Prince Harry asked what skin color
the baby was likely to be now Omid
claims that he knows who these people
are but he can't possibly say who they
are because of UK
laws but obviously in Holland you don't
have UK laws so as luck would have it
this translation that has appeared has
the names of the two people involved so
what's happened is that the you is that
the Dutch publisher has pulled these
titles off the shelves and said oh no we
couldn't possibly have meant to say that
but of course all the proof copies have
already gone out to all the editors and
reviewers and bloggers so every single
person in a position of public influence
in Holland who've been sent a copy of a
book will now know the identities of
these two people and it's it's hilarious
because scobby gave an interview to
Dutch television in which he said well
my version of the book doesn't have any
of this information in it you're
thinking what mean your version of a
book I mean are there about 10 different
versions would exist whereby your
version is just one of them and it's
it's hilarious really because you can
imagine this with that idea that you
know Camp Sussex has a dozen people out
there just like scopion that he's this
sort of he's not so much one person
there's about 10 of them so I mean all
lightness aside what you have to see is
that there is clearly something
happening from Camp Sussex and that I
mean Megan especially has been quite
quiet this year because Harry had spare
he's had all the publicity around that
and he's had
invictor but I mean all we've really
heard about her is this stuff about will
she be making a cameo in the last season
of suits and stuff like that and I think
one thing we've seen over the last half
decade is that mea marle is not a woman
who doesn't like publicity so what you
start to think to yourself is is she
going to be doing something via
intermediaries which is going to get her
side of the story back out there and
obviously the biggest detail from the
APR winrey interview that she inh har
did in 2021 Wass a hint about the idea
of his racist member of the royal family
and the fact that scobby has put this
detail into the book with this added
bonus name means that we to wonder well
how exactly has some translator in
Holland
decided I know I'm going to create the
biggest Royal news story of the year for
fun and it I mean none of it's adding up
and a lot of what's going on means that
they're treating you me and the average
person on the street like idiots I think
what we have to be asking is there is an
agenda and whose agenda is it and what
exactly is going on well talk about you
know speaking your Truth uh giving
one-sided accounts um what what are the
other main claims in this new book
obviously the racist Royal one is that's
dominates the headlines but I just
wondered from what we've heard and seen
so far are we expecting more of those
kind of Revelations or is it sort of a
one headline fact story what what what
was interesting for me is when I saw the
first stories of the book I thought
there's nothing new here I mean oh
Prince William wants to be king oh
Princess Kate is quite amable and she's
quite tame compared to Megan and Diana
oh you know there are tensions between
William and Harry and like I just kept
thinking everybody knows all this stuff
I mean literally nothing that I saw the
first weekends Revelations was of the
slightest surprise to me and I think
with what scobby and his Publishers may
have done is a kind of dead cat strategy
because finding Freedom which is a
rubbish book which scobby wrote a few
years ago about Harry and Megan escaping
from the cruel confins of a raw family
it was a massive bestseller because what
we're not used to in this country is the
idea that we we write books about the
royal family which are not hagiographies
which are just straightforward M green
gossip and I think that the fact that
the book was very critical of the RO
family and also very very flattering
about Harry and Megan meant there was a
market to that and so the Publishers
have decided that um endgame which I
thought would have nothing to do with
the Becket play but scobby quotes the
Becket play at the end so you see he's
intellectual as well as everything else
which is really really flattering I
think that the trouble that we now have
is that I mean what what's going to come
with new and you see ah if you name the
racist members of the raw family the
Dutch translation of a book so that it
helpfully goes viral the week of
publication so that when it eventually
comes out it gives you all the credit
and all the story that you couldn't have
put in the you I mean it's it's it's
clever
it's cynical and it's mavian but it's
clever and I just don't know who it's
coming from is it coming from his
publicists in which Cas you know give
all the Rays is it coming from scobby in
which case give him a Knighthood or as
is more likely is it coming from this
couple who have you know a huge amount
of power I mean they've they've got
deals with these I mean okay the deals
are slowly dwindling away because nobody
watched the Netflix series nobody
listened to the Apple podcasts or
Spotify podcasts
but nonetheless you're talking about a
huge amount of influence and so I cannot
believe that any of this is coincidental
or accidental Yeah you mentioned there
in your your sort of answer there the
nature of diminishing returns and
frankly how much is there a public
appetite a few years ago of course there
was Finding freedom but having heard so
much from Harry and Megan and The Wider
Camp Sussex Etc about what went on
during the years they were active Royals
I mean is there now a sense perhaps that
interest has waned in all of this hence
why perhaps we're seeing now Megan and
Harry keeping a slightly more dignified
silence in the hope that they could be
remitted to the
fault I think dignified silence is
putting it a bit strongly I think it's
more you send in your attack dog and
you're standing on the side and you're
placing bets on what your attack Do's
going to do but no I think that the
question that I have is that you know a
couple of weeks ago there was all this
story brief brief depress in great
detail about the reconciliation between
Harry and King Charles and then also the
same breath the idea that William and
Harry there is no reconciliation the two
are forever
estranged and what I want to know I mean
I'm because I'm fascinated by all this I
mean I I literally your equiv of your
popcorn munching punter is what is going
to I mean quite literally what is the
end game here
because I think Harry has done more
damage to the RO family than anybody
since saided would be eight probably
done more damage from as well because
least when he became J Windsor he just
packed him off the Bahamas made him
irrelevant whereas Harry in California
he's still this figure of international
Fascination and I mean while I don't
think he's clever Megan is clever and
you can see that between the two of them
you are working towards this solution
which I think is nothing less from the
demolition of the gr family as it stands
and in scobby they found a very useful
boswells of their Collective Johnson's
who is very happy to give them what they
want and I think it's both Sinister and
also fascinating because
ultimately Republicans everywhere are
going to be rejoicing at endgame because
they're going to see this book as the
absolute Vindication what they've been
saying for years but for the rest of us
you just think to yourself well are the
royal family really that awful are they
really the David Ike incarnation of them
as you know cheese eating lizards or
whatever Ike says these days or are they
in fact flawed human beings who are
placed on the international stage and
given far more scrutiny than any of us
would ever like and thus their flaws are
magnified far beyond what they actually
are Alexander thank you so much for
joining us on spectator TV
[Music]
today